comedy stuff huh
yeah but should it be painful anyway
next week is III the world's premiere
video game trade show a chance for
publishers to take the stage and show
off their way and we'd love to see it
when they do it perfectly everything
goes great but it's also kind of great
when everything goes wrong and sometimes
things do go deliciously well and then a
meme is born so naturally we've
collected some of the best memes from e3
past ego back in 2009 when
motion-tracking peripherals were still
chasing that crazy we money Microsoft
showed off Kinect for the first time
taking center stage was Kudo sonoda
stepped up to blow our minds with a
heretofore unseen look at the bottom of
an avatars shoe what followed was the
greatest Foot related myth since Lucy
yanked that football away from Charlie
Brown what BAM there it is good grief in
2006 Sony didn't have a great III with a
lot of backlash against the PlayStation
3 $600 price tag and a press conference
that was slightly awkward Ridge Racer
remember that one but our personal
favorite from the Sony show came when
game Republic's bill rich demo Genji
days of the blade for ps3 his claim that
the game was based on famous battles
which took actually took place in
ancient Japan took an unexpectedly
hilarious tone when he crabbed the size
of a house lepton screen and how mr.
rich did the samurai of Kamakura era
Japan tackled this giant enemy crab and
you attack its weak point
for massive damage Rich's enthusiasm for
one of the oldest tricks in the book
earned him full on meme status and you
can see his advice surface in other
games like Viva Pinata and Scribblenauts
remember this intro from Nintendo's e3
2004 press conference my name is Reggie
I'm about kicking ass I'm about taking
names and we're about making games
Reggie fils-aime a is a mean powerhouse
his pre Wii Fit Proclamation of my body
is ready quickly became the stuff of
internet legend and the regginator
himself even referenced it a few years
later with Wii Fit you yes my body was
ready memeing on your own meme that's
some next-level memory man and that same
year reg uttered the words which
launched a thousand photo shops I feel
just like a purple Pikmin when actress
and comedian Aisha Tyler first helmed
the Ubisoft press conference in 2012 she
did way more than make CEO Eve GMO look
like a hobbit she created her own meme
by professing that the Ubisoft presser
was giving her girl white well you he
did have a very good show that year she
caught some flak for her hashtag moment
from armchair critics the world around
all of whom must have purged their
memories of a certain other host that
Ubisoft once employed hey want to come
over and play my wii I don't want to
wish anyone ill per se but I really hope
we get some good ones next week come on
Reggie come on Reggie anyway of course
we're gonna be on the show for next week
at e3 so keep your eyes on GameSpot
because we're gonna be posting a
buttload of awesome video content just
gonna be up a lot I I really shouldn't
um could we do we do another one we'll
see you t---three please I don't want to
cool
you